everybody what is going on welcome to
another PI game with PI OpenGL and
Python tutorial video in this video
we're going to be building on the last
video where we actually made our little
cube here and you know it looks awesome
it's rotating sweet but now we want to
like learn a little bit more about you
know what went into making this cube how
we can modify it and what we can do
later on with those modifications so
suppose out of this and it's returned
back to this epoch paint window very
glad I didn't close this because I'm
going to use it again and again all
those might be lousy with this time what
we want to address is the actual surface
so the surface is um you know this right
so let's make let's say you know you've
got nodes so we've got node 1 2 3 4 5 5
6 7 and node 8 ok and then you have this
the actual surfaces here so let's say
this front surface is the one in
question so we fill it in and we lose
node 3
but this surface let's say we'd want to
address that surface that's the surface
between 5 6 7 & 8 okay and then we do
the same thing with the other one like
let's say this surface we want to
address this one well we could fill this
one in as well but it's between 1 2 5 6
this one would be 6 8 4 2 and so on so
that's what we want to talk about and
then we're also going to talk about some
of these functions that we covered in
the last video so like I said sometimes
if you're having a hard time visualizing
how these things work the best thing to
do if you're one of those people like a
real visual hands-on type of learner is
to let it pop up on the screen make a
couple adjustments repot it up see what
the difference is and you'll get a
better feel for for how things work so
the first thing I want us to go ahead
and do is let's make another list and
this will be the final list for us and
this list is going to be surfaces and
this is going to be a list again or a
tuple of tuples yeah
of all of the surfaces so how many
surfaces are there well we've got this
top one so we've got the sides let's say
one two three four you know around the
sides and then front and back would be
five and six so we've got six total
surfaces so let's go to copy paste two
three four five and six five six seven
eight let's make cubes so now we're
going to connect between all of the
nodes so obviously like we were saying
over here you've got one two three and
four those are all you know if that's a
face so to speak right like this right
here is a face so we're gonna fill in
that I really thought I had okay anyway
uh-huh
so one two three four is actually node
zero one two three
I should have done that in my example
I'm sorry one two and three and then the
next one let's say uh here you know of
it well the are my nodes here are not
identical so never mind don't use that
image anymore we're going to make the
connection between three to seven and
six that's a surface and then we've got
six seven five and four then we've got
four five one and zero and then we have
a one five seven two two and then we're
going to have a four to zero two three
and six and those are all of our
surfaces so then what do we do when we
want to write some GL code that's right
audience we have to encase it in GL
begin in GL end so we do the same thing
that we did here because this time it's
not lines right we're not drawing lines
anymore so this is not pertaining to
what we're about to do so we're going to
define some new ones
so again GL begin loosely bit params for
now GL end so beginning in that stuff
what are we doing this time we're doing
GL quads baby so that's our GL constant
right there and then now we're going to
say this time for surface in surfaces
what do we want to do so that's for each
of these
in the services and all these numbers
right correspond to the node or the
vertex or each of the vertices and so
for surface and surfaces um normally we
would do something here I guess we'll
just we'll throw in the color like you
could do GL color 3fv and then you throw
in a color here so and these are
basically zero minimum one is maximum so
like for example this would make green
um-hmm not positive but let's go ahead
and run this see what happens right so
we still have a one more thing we need
to do because we have not finished so
let's go ahead and close this and so
we've done we've done this and then what
we need to do next is call for vertex in
a surface surface GL vertex 3fv
and then again here we just do vertices
vertex and this code I mean this so this
will work in theory it should right so
now we have a cube um it may be you know
as it moves we can see it's clearly a
cube but we're kind of maybe having a
hard time recognizing that it's a cube
but let me close out of this real quick
and just specify something to so we
could take this here we cut and paste
like that and you see it's like the
exact same thing but then also what if
we were to take this and put it like
right here okay so you see how it's
making like no change at all so what
where we put it how does it matter so if
we put it here this basically sets like
the constant color period for this GL
block that we're doing if we put it here
under for surface and surfaces it
literally is for surface and surfaces
and then same thing here but if it's the
same color
then it's just it's not going to make
any difference where we slap this but
let's go ahead and make a quick colors
list here colors equals and then let's
go ahead and make a few colors shall we
I really should have copy and paste it
but that's okay this will do for now
we'll just make some of these colors so
let's do a 1 0 0 0 1 0 0 0 1 0 0 0 1 1 1
and then 0 1 1 ok those are our colors
we have 6 colors let's go ahead and just
we'll just copy this once and paste to
see why in a minute but we'll do that
since the max thing we have is 12 so now
we've got 12 different colors now we can
do like this um we'll just say x equals
0 um x plus equals 1 let's say and for
surface and surfaces then we'll say the
color here is colors X see where this
yeah okay so you can see that now we've
like colored some of the edges but we're
still not totally a happy yet um the
next thing I want to show let's take ah
when you do let's change this to a 1
like this to 1 let me try this one let
me try this thing I didn't really change
anything major um okay so anyways let me
close out of this this uh so so that
gave us like whole face colors but what
if we did like some this like um try to
think of how I'm gonna get away with
this I guess we could take this do this
and then do take this and do
is see if we get away with that right so
in this scenario we've changed the game
a little bit because what we're doing is
instead of for each surface we're saying
for each vertice and you see we get this
lovely multicolored just absolute fun
stuff so anyway fun to play with that
well we can leave that for now so now uh
the other things I just wanted to run
through really quick sorry to take up
all your time
but let's like comment this out for now
um the GL rotate let's go ahead and save
and run that real quick right so now
we've got a back to being stationary and
now what we want to do is this is the
translate if you recall this is XY and z
so this translate for example that is
like our relation to the object so if we
make this v let's run this apparently
too much let's make it one there we go
so we've shifted over the x value by one
unit we can do the same thing to Y let's
shift Y by one and now it's up a bit
so we've shift our perspective there as
well conversely we could do something
like this like 0.5 okay so now it's
close it's not as much up as noticed
here um the other thing we can do
obviously we have rotate that's by uh
degrees and then you've got XY let's say
two here so now you see we've kind of
like rotated up a little bit on the cube
and then let's return this guy zero zero
perspective the clipping I have to show
you guys a clipping one I think I'll
save that for the next video the next
video will be much more exciting in this
video I promise although colors is
indeed very fun so anyway yeah I think
we'll have to wait
until the next video but I will just say
if you're a little confused about
vertices and edges you can always do
stuff like this right so vertices
negative one Oh in fact you know what
let's go ahead and put this back to like
25 2 & 1
let's save and run that really quick
sorry let's see where we are now ok
let's get rid of this displacement that
we've added here so let's put that back
to 0 & 0
good enough so now what we want to do
what the last thing I really wanted to
show in this one what was it I don't
remember what it was now I like blanked
out for you guys oh right right I hit
the vertices okay so you remember what
that one looked like now it's 2 negative
2 for this one say we moved that node
see how I like mess this up a little bit
another thing that we could do for
example is we could change that but now
it's like Miss order the vertices so
we'll cut this one put it down here and
then we'll cut this one put it here and
then let's cut this one and put it here
this is a white vertice order matters so
save and run that oh okay this one
doesn't have a comma after it so let's
add that comma right so now you've got
this like jumbled up cube so that's why
it's important that you specify the
order correctly to PI OpenGL now that is
also why people many times have
functions that create the object for
them specifically for that reason so you
do they don't mess it up
right because because if you have a
function that does that you basically
say that where you want it maybe or the
starting point and then and that's it
right you're not going to have any
trouble with like user error so punch
you just need to write the function one
time and you never have to do it do that
again and like visualize it again but
for someone who's trying to learn OpenGL
and like PI OpenGL for example that's
really confusing trying to figure out
what the heck that function even does
you know so anyway hopefully that's of
use to you guys on the next video what
we're talking about is getting user
input to change so right now this is
automatic but how could we actually get
user input to change you know our
perspective on this live besides just
having it rotate for us so I'll show you
guys how you can zoom in and now and
maybe how we can go like left right or
up and down that kind of stuff so to be
a good fun so stay tuned for that and if
you guys have any questions or comments
on this video please feel free to leave
them below otherwise as always thanks
for watching thanks for all the support
and subscriptions and until next time